I took the time to wear this thing can't
even see it it just goes below the
friend like I'm wearing any other rope
based necklace whatever so on YouTube
there's this 15 minute or so fan film
it's an uncharted fan film it's a
live-action fan film and it stars who
the fans wants as Nathan Drake who's
Nathan Fillion does again you know this
dude is like now not marketable enough I
won't lie even at this point I was like
you might be a bit too old to play
Nathan Drake but this one takes place
after the first couple games so I guess
it works because I would think he'd be
about that old for uncharted for it
looks like the third or fourth moving
and Uncharted franchise and we're just
skipping ahead but really this is a
testament to agents neither here nor
there
I'm sure Jack Nicholson was a bit too
old to play the Joker but when you've
got the perfect guy you got the perfect
guy and you used the perfect guy you
play uncharted Nathan Drake's clearly
Nathan Fillion totally modeled after him
I love the simplicity and or charming
and endearing quality of this fan films
clearly someone who was like I want to
do an uncharted movie how an uncharted
movie should be and when you're watching
it it so comes across like the game you
can't help but realize that a studio
would not make it feel like that studio
doesn't it won't be comparable to the
game we know that for a fact but this
one totally is comparable to the game
Fillion brings the snarky quality that
Nathan Drake needs a couple of jokes he
just made me laugh and if I'm being
honest about it for the first couple
lines that Nathan Fillion spoke in here
I was like it is slightly different than
Nathan Drake by slightly different what
I'm trying to say is there are some
lines where Nathan Fillion as Nathan
Drake says in Nathan Drake line or
Nathan Drake ish line since its original
for this short film it sounds like
Nathan Fillion saying in Nathan Drake
lines whereas other times Nathan Fillion
as Nathan Drake says in Nathan Drake
line and it's absolutely the same the
point is Nathan Drake may have started
out as a Nathan Fillion emulation but
he's become his own man his own
character who is a bit different than
Nathan Fillion which is testament to
Nolan North how he made Nathan Drake his
own so good on him doesn't change the
fact that if you're trying to capture
that Nathan Drake quality for live
action Nathan Fillion is the man to do
it yes the snarkiness he has the [ __ ]
talk he has the carefree attitude that
was kind of a ruse because we know
Nathan Drake cares
it has Stephen Lang as Sully wasn't been
my first pick for Sully I don't know if
he was their first pick for Sully either
he kind of comes across as Sully's
slightly more hardcore brother like
Sully if he did a little bit of time
maybe it's because it's Stephen Lang and
I'm used to Stephen Lang playing
villains
David lang for his part does a good job
with Sully I'm just impressed with the
fact that this even happened it's like a
lot of us fans talk about what we want
to see but we don't do anything to make
it happen and now someone just did it
right it's only 15 minutes long but it
does leave off with there's more it
leaves off in a kind of to be continued
capacity I don't know if this was a demo
I don't know if they're gonna use this
to pitch it to something else this is
what I know if YouTube is smart they
will make them an offer that will
financially back it they will make it a
YouTube read series and they should have
a winner on their hands it's gonna be
the next Cobra Kai that thing you're
like I didn't know this was gonna happen
but now that it has it totally worked
meanwhile Hollywood's like we can't see
the vision our heads up our ass we don't
know what to do but I do know I love
this 15 minute fan film and I would love
to see more Hollywood go ahead and drop
your ambitions for Uncharted let these
folks take it over they'll run with the
torch you've been crawling with for the
past few years so I have a link below to
the Uncharted fan film starring Nathan
Fillion I have a link below to the
Uncharted fan dream we've been dreaming
about for years check it out I'd love to
know your thoughts and if you've seen it
why did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]